so why are you excited to play LeBron
just because he's LeBron he's one of the
goats well I know he's most definitely
in the conversation with you know Jordan
all the guys so I think just you know
being out there with him on the court
hopefully I don't have my rookie moments
against him it's definitely going on
every social media prob can go out there
make it hard for him he makes it he
makes it get a good picture frame
it yeah what one word describe BR
physical every time you get it he
driving using his body get all kind of
bumps and ones he's on the line then
that's definitely a 40 Point year now
he's been in League a minute you want to
play that long I want to have a career
in the league 10 years plus with Bronze
Age that's hard on the body I don't know
how you do it that's love for the game
for
[Music]
sure